[Music]
i think
directing is hostage negotiation with
reality you have a plan and then reality
comes and takes a hostage and says if
you don't solve it i'll blow its hand
and you go oh give me a moment give me
one what if we do this how much are the
the the visuals leading
the story and how much is the story
informing the visuals it's absolutely
absolutely harmonious thing
like i
uh because i sustained that image
is story
it's as you said music and lyrics it's a
song how many of you saw the movie
great all right we can go to this guy
you didn't see it
god damn it
well please step aside
no matter what your problem is there is
always one elegant and perfect solution
and simple
to every problem you're going to
encounter in all your years of directing
and it's your duty to be open and
permeable to find it nightmare alley is
stylish and beautiful and flows sort of
like a dream but is the real world
still
shape of water is one notch one notch or
two above
because you cannot have a fish guy show
up in a realistic movie and say hey
how's it hanging you know
live in the culture
live in the arts that is your oxygen
not just cinema
live in architecture understand painting
understand sculpture be moved
by these things know that language
because cinema encompasses it all